l'agent un père de famille heureux à la
suite d'une brève chirurgie au genou pas
trop d'attentes que je pourrai retrouver
le magma mobilité que j'avais avant ce
qui est merveilleux
une opération défrayés par l'état mais
réalisé dans la clinique privée
chirurgie 10 30
ces salles d'opération un petit hôpital
à la fine pointe de la technologie
chocques si on les prend en charge une
simple rapidement on se sent vraiment de
la clinique comme moi j'ai l'impression
d'être dans une clinique suisse
ophtalmologiques gastro entérologie et
même orthopédie une gamme de chirurgie
d'un jour que le réseau public peine à
réaliser en raison de la pandémie
contenu de la part des me compte tenu
des retards pour les deux trois
prochaines années le réseau a besoin
d'assistance et on est devenu un
partenaire du réseau
donc ce n'est pas dupe brisé mais c'est
plutôt du partenariat public privé
les patients sont envoyés ici par les
hôpitaux de toute la montérégie et même
du sud de l'île de montréal
on a plus de demandes qu'on est capable
de répondre ce genre de ppp gagne en
popularité dans plusieurs régions le sus
de l'est de l'île de montréal mandate
une clinique privée pour réaliser 8
millions en chirurgie laval sous traite
près de 4 millions en orthopédie et en
estrie une clinique reçoit un mandat de
trois millions sept cent mille dollars
en ophtalmologie
depuis l'automne la somme des contrats
donnés par le public au secteur privé en
chirurgie dépasse les 80 millions la
demande du réseau public est si forte
que chirurgie dix30 prend de l'expansion
ici on a on est dans l'une des deux
salles qu'on ajoute construction
principalement pour faire de leur
technologie pour deux nouvelles salles
d'opération en ophtalmologie
pour faire plus de chirurgie
orthopédique ailleurs dans la clinique
attirant pour les orthopédistes dont
plusieurs au père moitié moins qu'avant
la pandémie je pense pas que les gens va
délaisser du système public
c'est juste que on est les chirurgiens
opèrent une fois par semaine donc il
reste encore quatre jours là où on peut
optimiser avec la hausse des cas de
covin le délestage des opérations a
repris et le réseau aurait accumulé un
retard d'au moins deux ans les cliniques
de chirurgie privés risquent donc d'être
très sollicité au cours des prochaines
années
ici david gêne-t-il et réseaux canada
brossât